la détenue s'exprime avec difficulté
elle a un peu de mal à tenir debout
quelques secondes plus tard la jeune
femme a du mal à remettre sa chaussure
les surveillantes pensent tout de suite
à un abus de médicaments Karine va
alerter le psychiatre
[Musique]
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauvé secourir protéger finalement je
suis journaliste
alors j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre
de ces hommes et de ces femmes
ordinaires qui exercent des métiers hors
du commun
capitaine sécurité
aujourd'hui je débarque dans l'une des
prisons les plus modernes de France la
maison d'arrêt de Nantes donc là on a
chez les femmes
570 donc 40 pour les femmes 250
surveillants deux détenus maximum par
cellule il n'est pas du tout confortable
vous en avez conscience ici la présente
une caméra est exceptionnelle je vais y
rester quatre jours et essayer de capter
la nouvelle philosophie de la
pénitentiaire
des prisons de la République j'en ai
déjà vu et j'ai en tête l'image de celle
qu'on veut cacher les vieilles coques
surpeuplées et insalubre cellules
minuscules douche fétide chauffage
défectueux
mais j'évite compris que
l'administration souhaite me montrer
autre chose du neuf du modèle
[Musique]
je me retrouve donc catapulté à Nantes à
la maison d'arrêt de Carquefou le
fleuron de la pénitentiaire du 21e
siècle
donc voilà l'établissement où j'étais
affecté par le ministère de la Justice
pour passer quatre jours pour découvrir
l'endroit ils n'ont pas choisi le plus
vétuste de leur établissement c'est une
maison d'arrêt de dernière génération
c'est plutôt un endroit où
sont placés des courtes peines allez
c'est parti
donc là il faut apprendre à se passer de
son téléphone portable toute la journée
ce qui est plutôt un soulagement
cette maison d'arrêt a été ouverte en
juin 2012 c'est la dernière année des
prisons de la République 24 mois de
travaux pour un montant global de 82
millions d'euros
objectif améliorer les conditions de
détention et les conditions de travail
des surveillance deux lits maximum par
cellule chaque cellule fait 10 mètres
carrés toutes sont équipées de douches
et de toilettes
fini les réfectoires communs ici on
mange devant la télé
objectivement c'est assez laid mais au
moins c'est neuf et c'est propre
et les puces électroniques ont pris le
pouvoir
[Musique]
du lieu où ils doivent se déplacer
architecture froide et un personnel
couloir interminable
circulation
ultra contrôlée
250 caméras disséminés
de quoi dissuader tout rêve d'évasion
je croise un détenu qui a connu
l'ancienne prison de Nantes la vieille
prison
est-ce que le comportement des
surveillants a changé depuis que ils
sont dans ce nouveau décor on va dire
qu'ils sont plus un peu plus strict
quand même plus strict pourquoi parce
que bon ils sont plus strictes c'est
filmé il y a des caméras partout
maintenant
donc si nous on est on se sent des pieds
au moindre gestes eux c'est pareil
je vais rester quatre jours et vite
plusieurs visages vont devenir familiers
Emmanuel 45 ans le marchand de bonheur
de l'établissement
Karine la trentaine une âme de chef à la
tête de la MAAF la maison d'arrêt des
femmes on va procéder
au Jérôme ancien ouvrier d'usine
surveillant du quartier disciplinaire le
tristement célèbre mitard
le capitaine de ce navire au 700 portes
c'est Jean-Marie landais 42 ans le
directeur
deux fois par semaine il réunit toute
son équipe pour étudier le dossier de
tous ses pensionnaires
[Musique]
il doit surtout comme dans un hôpital
veillez à ne pas dépasser la capacité de
ces 570 litres et c'est pas évident
il y avait 9 places de disponibles sur
la maison d'arrêt une 5 sur la maison
d'arrêt 2 cette prison a beau être l'une
des plus récentes de France elle est
déjà au bord de l'asphyxie
et conserver une capacité minimum
d'accueil relève chaque semaine d'un
tour de force
donc la stratégie c'est d'affecter sur
les places disponibles sur nos deux
maisons d'arrêt les personnes qui ne
pour lesquels on a des possibilités
d'affectation correcte ça va donner
libérer des places au quartier arrivant
pour faire face aux arrivants
d'aujourd'hui et de ce soir avec un peu
de chance ça sera suffisant en gros
aujourd'hui vous pouvez accepter que
trois nouveaux détenus ça serait bien
qu'il y en ait pas plus
il y a des audiences correctionnelles
aujourd'hui quand même donc vous pouvez
vous retrouver avec des mandats de dépôt
c'est pas impossible fin d'après midi
c'est pas impossible donc on va mettre
des matelas donc on espère que non
au suivant
vous avez bien compris le fonctionnement
Jean-Marie Landé ne ressemble pas au
directeur d'autrefois il ne dirige pas
une prison il la gère comme un chef
d'entreprise et d'ailleurs le
recrutement des cadres aussi a changé le
maton s'efface peu à peu avant on les
appelait avec mes prix les portes-clés
à moi personnellement j'ai un cursus
artisan à la base sur la tisana pendant
pas mal d'années moi j'ai un cursus
linguistique à la base j'ai fait une
faculté de langues étrangères donc moi
ce qui me plaît dans ce métier c'est
justement d'animer des équipes où il y a
des personnalités comme ça tout à fait
diverses les gens différents qui ont des
parcours différents et c'est justement
la richesse du travail
[Musique]
direction le quartier des arrivants
c'est là que débarque chaque semaine une
vingtaine de nouveaux détenus qui vont
rester ici une semaine le temps de faire
connaissance
qui fait le tri un travail de profiler
car il y a de tout des endurci des
suicidaires des délinquants occasionnels
alors pas question de placer le nouveau
n'importe où ou avec n'importe qui c'est
le prix de la paix et de la sécurité
et puis tout le monde ne peut pas avoir
une cellule individuelle
[Musique]
je vais pouvoir
déterminer si la du potentiel agressif
agressif pas du tout
[Musique]
agressifs
il faut respecter une partie de la
est-ce que vous avez aussi
des périodes où vous avez envie de vous
couper vous pouvez me montrer
[Musique]
et puis je vous dis à plus tard bonne
journée
on voit bien que ça intéressant vous
faites et vous êtes
formés ou formé par le temps pour
repérer un psychopathe un psychotique
savoir qu'il est probablementaux oui
c'est une grosse part des gens qui
arrivent ici
de plus en plus c'est ça qui est
de psychologie d'où sang-froid et
beaucoup de patience voilà les qualités
requises pour faire face dans l'une de
ces cellules deux jeunes qui se
connaissent profitent de leur connivence
pour défier l'autorité des surveillants
il faut garder la tête froide
[Musique]
complètement de photo
à écourter un petit peu la phase
d'accueil si ça sert à rien et si ils
sont vraiment dans le rapport de force
on va donc laisser séparer et si ça ne
suffit pas ce sera le quartier
disciplinaire
ce qu'on appelle mitard c'est ça
genre de fautes moyennes surtout des
agressions sur personnel agression sur
sur des murs
[Musique]
pour éviter tout contact avec les autres
détenus le quartier disciplinaire le qd
est situé à l'opposé du reste de la
détention on y accède par un
interminable couloir
glacial le couloir
il y a plein de raisons de placer un
détenu à l'isolement pour le protéger
pour protéger les autres pour ne pas
qu'il ait changé avec un complice dans
une enquête en cours
les surveillants qui travaillent ici ont
été choisis pour leur sang-froid Jérôme
ancien ouvrier en l'usine ouvre les
portes avec précaution
alors c'est quoi la technique
pour pouvoir rouler la personne et puis
toujours les clés dans la main d'accord
toujours enfin et après dès que je vais
ouvrir je remets le peine je ressors Le
Pen d'accord afin que si jamais il y
avait un autre incident
je me retrouve pas enfin la porte puisse
pas être refermée
de base en clair Jérôme n'aimerait pas
être prise en otage
l'un des détenus de l'étage est signalé
comme particulièrement dangereux au
moment d'ouvrir sa cellule on me demande
de ne pas m'exposer le truc en fait
quand il sort
de sa cellule aussi
vous allez voir de loin de toute façon
il est violent et des titanesses qu'il
est voilà et en tout cas il est
potentiellement violent et
potentiellement dangereux même vous vous
en méfiez
on est sur le qui-vive à chaque fois
qui est en attente de jugement a déjà
tué plusieurs fois notamment un code
détenu je l'aperçois il est titanesque
nous passons dans l'autre partie le côté
des puni le fameux mitard donc là on est
dans une cellule type de quartier
disciplinaire les éléments qui sont au
sol tout est visible
le lavabo mais bon
vous devez
il est pas du tout confortable ce mec là
vous en avez conscience
probablement c'est fait pour ça c'est
important comme mieux on n'a pas du tout
la même approche avec le détenu et tout
seul on parle calmement avec lui donc le
surveillant parle beaucoup avec lui
ouais
pourquoi il y a eu cette attitude
violence ou le fait qu'il porte lui-même
une réflexion c'est déjà pas mal
l'expression de la violence est vraiment
sur le système de communication
l'ambiance n'est pas joasse mais Jérôme
est très enthousiaste
je suis pas l'usine je suis plus à
l'usine je voyais j'ai cette détenue ici
faut que je rentre 7 c'est tout après
c'est à moi de voir pour que il soit
satisfait ou non de mes services c'est
c'est du relationnel c'est c'est
bien discuter la psychologie je veux
dire tout ça sur le tas bien sûr
vous êtes formés pour ça on est formé et
puis après ça nous former
on lit certains livres plus que d'autres
on regarde certaines émissions plus que
d'autres et puis je dis pas que j'ai un
abonnement à psychologique un magazine
mais c'est plus enrichissant que ah oui
oui
[Musique]
en prison la journée des détenus se
termine vers 18h après le passage de la
gamelle
une heure plus tard les équipes de nuit
prennent leur service je vais rester un
peu pour voir
vous allez où donc là on va aller au
niveau du PC
dans la journée environ 80 surveillants
sont de services et sa fourmi mais le
soir la prison est silencieuse
enveloppée dans la nuit on dirait
qu'elle est vide
vous demandez combien il y a de
personnes la 12 12 + -
vous libérez des gens et vous en fait
rentrer
tout ça très sur la maison d'arrêt
principale
le soir ils ne sont que 13 surveillants
qui doivent en plus accueillir de
nouveaux arrivants
ce soir le client que nous allons
accueillir n'a pas l'air très stressé un
habitué manifestant bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
il est détendu mais vu l'encombrement de
la prison il est peu probable qu'il est
le choix de sa cellule
ah j'aime le critère
[Musique]
avec couverture plateau et tout ce qui
est nécessaire d'hygiène serviette gants
de toilette dans cette ville il y a
quoi
des lieux de la cellule non seulement le
jeu d'homme connaît bien la maison mais
il semble bien connaître aussi ses
occupants
et vous connaissez depuis combien de
temps les deux là
ça fait des années et d'où le PM et par
rapport à la prison
le nouvel arrivant est très exigeant
j'en suis estomaqué
que ce nouveau détenu passera sa
première nuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce matin j'ai rendez-vous avec une
surveillante grâce à elle je vais
découvrir un quartier particulier
une petite trentaine chef de la maison
d'arrêt des femmes la MAAF
donc là on est chez les femmes
il y en a combien
ce matin les surveillante de la MAAF
encadrent une opération un peu spéciale
l'une des détenus est incarcérée avec
son bébé et pour la première fois le
nourrisson va quitter la prison pour
passer la journée dans une crèche à
l'extérieur
[Musique]
se sociabilise un petit peu
au début quoi
elle c'est la première fois qu'elle le
laisse partir
pour la sortie de l'enfant toute la
prison est bloquée a commencé par le
quartier des femmes lui-même
on doit isoler le bébé par rapport aux
yeux personnellement il n'y a aucune
personne devient des tensions normales
qui doit croiser voilà
[Musique]
et puis on a quand même des mers qui
sont là pour les enfants ici donc tu
peux répondre
[Musique]
Karine m'emmène dans l'aile nursery ou
la maman attend avec son bébé 3
bénévoles d'une association qui vont se
charger d'escorter l'enfant jusqu'à la
crèche sont déjà là et maintenant il
faut rassurer la mer
et bonjour comment allez-vous
bonjour
je rigole
il est prêt pour sa première sortie
[Musique]
il est bien traité ici finalement
parce que il y a quand même des bruits
tout le monde de la journée des filles
qui des fois qui s'amusent avec les
barreaux de l'armure elle qui sont les
barreaux tous les après-midi donc mais
ça va à peu près fait
bonne journée madame
[Musique]
après une journée à la crèche bébé
retrouvera sa maman derrière les
barreaux
[Musique]
de retour dans le quartier des femmes
j'observe Karine elle a de la poigne
dans son secteur la direction lui a
donné carte blanche et je vois bien
qu'elle est en leader appréciée et
qu'avec elle tout est sous contrôle
[Musique]
si un changement de comportement
tournante vraiment
rien ne vous échappe en fait
[Musique]
à l'ouverture de l'établissement Karina
a elle-même organisé ce quartier avec
une totale autonomie évidemment pas
question de croiser les hommes toutes
les activités des femmes se déroulent
dans le même bâtiment activités
formation professionnelle et quartier
disciplinaire
comment on devient première surveillante
à quel âge quel âge avez-vous
je suis rentrée à 21 ans dans
l'administration et j'ai eu mon concours
à 28 ans de première surveillance petite
trentaine
vous avez passé un concours pour devenir
surveillance et puis même on peut on
peut changer même en étant
on peut faire autre chose c'est ça qui
est intéressant et vous êtes au tout
début de l'histoire et je suis au tout
début de l'histoire
[Musique]
le quartier des femmes est comme une île
à l'intérieur de la prison mais il y a
aussi un endroit encore plus étonnant
[Musique]
dans cet aile de la prison le patron
s'est Emmanuel
[Musique]
son domaine ce sont les UVF les unités
de vie familiale le long de ce couloir
plusieurs petits appartements permettent
aux détenus et à leurs proches de se
retrouver de façon très exceptionnelle
pour des périodes allant de 6 à 72
heures
aujourd'hui en France pour 67 000
détenus il existe une soixantaine
d'unités de vie familiale comme celle-ci
c'est pour la réinsertion en fait des
détenus
pour les habituer comme ils sont restés
incarcérés un certain temps tout ce qui
est vie familiale ils l'ont un petit peu
oublié et d'avoir un petit peu cet accès
avec leur famille ici ça leur permet un
petit peu de revoir leur préparé à
manger les couches et les border leur
raconter une petite histoire enfin qui
ne peuvent pas avoir au niveau des n'a
pas l'avoir simple
[Musique]
pas facile d'obtenir un UVF le détenu
fait l'objet d'une enquête interne et
doit justifier d'un comportement
irréprochable les familles font
également l'objet d'une investigation
[Musique]
on lance notre enquête il y a des
familles des fois qu'ils sont un petit
peu sous tension avec les détenus qui
sont pas ils viennent au parloir mais
passer 6 heures dans un UVF sont
peut-être pas
intéressés donc on leur demande
également de nous écrire une lettre
manuscrite pour connaître un petit peu
leurs intentions savoir c'est pourquoi
ils veulent venir également voir le la
personne détenue
nous quittons un instant la prison pour
gagner un petit pavillon réservé à
l'accueil des familles
Emmanuel a donné rendez-vous à une jeune
femme qui vient visiter aujourd'hui son
petit ami
je vérifie juste qu'il n'y ait pas de
choses coupantes ou autre impeccable
voilà ensuite on a un paquet de
cigarettes qui est bien fermé nickel
briquet vous avez mis
aux côtés des manuels la jeune femme
découvre l'intérieur de la prison
mais elle est au cœur de la détention
nous avons récupéré le détenu à l'autre
bout de la détention mais avant de
l'abandonner à ses 6 heures de bonheur
il faut faire l'état des lieux
alors les toilettes
la lumière qui fonctionne aspirateur les
draps
d'oreiller toutes choses que vous
utilisez les torchons ou autre à la
sortie vous mettrez ça dans le bac et
puis vous avez moi je vois le visage de
ce jeune détenu il semblerait tout
éveillé
c'est bien non
c'est vrai que vous avez l'air d'un
agent immobilier quand vous faites ça
il ne reste plus à Emmanuel qu'à
accompagné la jeune femme jusqu'à
l'appartement pendant le temps que va
durer le VF les deux jeunes gens ne
seront reliés au surveillants que par un
interphone enfermé à double tour ils
vont s'évader quelques heures c'est bien
je suis content ça fait plaisir ça
change est-ce que c'est difficile pour
un garçon de votre âge de pas avoir de
relation sexuelle pendant 8 mois c'est
dur quand même
[Musique]
allez nous on s'en va on vous laisse
Ciao
bye
[Musique]
loin des retrouvailles d'un couple
d'amoureux au quartier disciplinaire
Jérôme et son équipe ont du fil à
retordre
[Musique]
je sais pas
c'est comme des vacances
il est 7h20 du matin dans
l'administration pénitentiaire on
travaille
il y a pas su exprimer sa colère
autrement que par la violence
écouter
[Musique]
Monsieur le Directeur
pour une raison totalement
incompréhensible ce détenu semble enragé
[Musique]
qui vient de lâcher
pour le forcené l'addition risque d'être
salée
[Musique]
Jérôme et ses collègues décident
d'attendre d'attendre que le détenu se
fatigue pour pouvoir reprendre le
dialogue
la nuit est tombée le détenu n'est
toujours pas calmé Jérôme quitte son
service pour deux jours de repos
ce sont ses collègues qui demain devront
régler le problème
ce matin Emmanuel m'attend devant
l'enceinte le temps pour lui de se
raconter un peu les métiers qu'il a fait
avant et sa vocation pour la prison qui
date de son service militaire
[Musique]
uniforme je pense que c'est ça ah
l'autorité de l'uniforme les choses
comme ça je pense que c'est ça qui m'a
qui m'a donné l'envie de faire ce métier
ce matin Emmanuel endos l'uniforme
d'enquêteur un détenu a fait une demande
pour obtenir un premier séjour en unité
de vie familiale donc ce détenu a
demandé à avoir annuaire avec sa
compagne donc là c'est la première
demande donc là on va aller lui
expliquer comment ça fonctionne lui voir
avec lui les différentes choses si s'il
travaille s'il a des formations s'il va
au sport etc on va regarder avec lui si
il a également des des sources sur son
compte pour pouvoir continuer c'est
obligatoire s'il y a pas d'argent il
pourra pas continuer pour pour sa
famille pour nourrir sa famille voilà
c'est lui qui nourrit exactement et le
problème c'est que s'il a pas de sous il
a donc pas de cantine pas de cantine pas
du VF
pour responsabiliser le détenu
l'administration l'oblige à financer les
repas de sa famille durant le séjour au
sein de la prison
[Musique]
autant dire que pour ce jeune homme
l'entretien qui va suivre et
d'importance
[Musique]
ok le nom de la personne qui vient vous
visiter c'est votre concubine c'est ça
ok nickel
le problème c'est qu'Emmanuel a remarqué
que le pécule du détenu et maigrelet
pour le travail
en ce qui concerne le travail ou la
formation est-ce que vous avez soit
demandé où j'ai vu préface en commission
le 10 janvier pour pour le travail c'est
le travail bon c'est parfait
le jeune homme a fait bonne impression
et Emmanuel a eu le temps de s'assurer
que sa famille lui envoie régulièrement
un peu d'argent la vie sera donc
favorable vous êtes prêt à attendre un
mois un mois et demi encore là
il y a pas de sexualité
au revoir
dans une prison toutes les portes se
ressemblent mais au troisième jour je
commence à m'y retrouver il faut dire
qu'avec les accompagnateurs qui me
chaperonnent en permanence je ne risque
pas de me perdre c'est drôle ça qui
sache ils sont plus au courant
[Musique]
on va procéder au retour promenade
et je suis autorisé à assister à ce
retour promenade chez les femmes ici on
appelle ça un mouvement
on est bien ici c'est 100 fois plus
calme que chez eux-mêmes
c'est doux il y a une douceur qui a pas
ailleurs
c'est
en fait
mais j'ai parlé un peu vite chez les
femmes la violence existe aussi sous
d'autres formes
la discussion avec cette détenue à l'air
anodine mais karine a remarqué quelque
chose d'étrange
[Musique]
la détenue s'exprime avec difficulté
elle a un peu de mal à tenir debout
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que vous allez du mal à
mon avis
[Musique]
quelques secondes plus tard la jeune
femme a du mal à remettre sa chaussure
les surveillantes pensent tout de suite
à un abus de médicaments Karine va
alerter le psychiatre
je prends juste ce qu'il faut mais ça et
effectivement
accordé et
du coup on la trouve encore plus tonna
et l'autre elle prend quoi comme
médicament
je ne sais pas ce serait médical
les traitements
c'est ça le quotidien de Karine et de
son équipe autant de cas particuliers
que de détenus
j'abandonne les femmes pour foncer avec
le directeur au quartier disciplinaire
il y a du nouveau là-bas le forcené
c'est calmé et a accepté de rencontrer
Jean-Marie Landé en tête à tête en cas
de problème une équipe devra se tenir
prête à intervenir
l'idée c'est d'avoir les moyens de
d'intervention au cas où ça se passe mal
notamment si refuse de retourner dans la
cellule et donc d'être le plus discret
possible si ça se passe bien tant mieux
et puis si par contre il y a une
difficulté je saurai je saurai vous
appeler
[Musique]
dans l'équipe d'intervention je retrouve
une vieille connaissance Emmanuel mon
copain des UVF a été appelé en renfort
ça change les gentils
[Musique]
c'est toujours
on appuie ça fait un groupe compact
l'équipe d'intervention se positionne
pour ne pas rajouter de tension les
trois hommes devront se tenir hors de
vue du détenu que l'on va extraire de sa
cellule il se rend cachés dans une pièce
située juste à côté du bureau on va se
dérouler l'entretien
et vous attendez mon feu vert si je peux
dire
si je suis pas en capacité par contre de
m'exprimer là
moi on m'a installé dans un bureau aux
vitres teintées d'où j'aperçois l'homme
au moment où il sort de sa cellule je
l'avais imaginé plus costaud que ça
impossible de filmer l'entretien qui va
durer une dizaine de minutes
comme moi
le sous-directeur reste en retrait
c'est fini c'est fini
apparemment tout s'est bien déroulé et
l'équipe d'intervention n'a pas eu à
entrer en action maintenant il ne reste
plus au surveillant qu'à changer le
jeune homme de cellule puisque celle où
il se trouvait désormais
inutilisable bien entendu il sera
sanctionné pour ses actes et moi
je constate les dégâts
oui il y a pas grand chose qui peut
faire quoi
c'est lui qui a écrit tout ça
fait maintenant juste pour te venger de
la haine des Arabes macaques
mais ça n'est pas tout avec l'interphone
qu'il avait arraché le détenu s'était
confectionné une arme très dangereuse
qui peut être quand même dangereuse pour
les personnes
tout incidents
de la République qui lui au vu des
éléments qu'on lui transmet peut
demander
c'est sérieux
que de temps perdu pour lui
[Musique]
ce soir c'est ma dernière nuit en prison
j'accompagne la ronde que font les deux
surveillants qui se partagent le
contrôle des 500 cellules de
l'établissement
de regarder les hommes
ah oui et des fois c'est pas gênant
parce que vous entrez dans leur intimité
[Musique]
fin de la première ronde
direction le greffe on libère ce soir un
jeune homme qui a purgé une peine de 2
mois pour détention de stupéfiants un
petit délinquant qui n'est pas prêt
d'oublier l'expérience
c'était long mais combien de temps à peu
près
peut-être
vous savez pas si c'est un ou deux
à quelle heure vous avez appris que vous
étiez libérer
[Musique]
je suis avec ma mère alors je vais pas
faire la drague
je suis content je dois rentrer chez moi
je crois que les surveillants non plus
ne sont pas près d'oublier ceux détenus
particulièrement honnête je vais vous
rendre la somme de 482 euros 68 ok
problème c'est pas ça c'est trop c'est
trop
j'aime pas ça c'est normal que je vous
ai mis 80 euros de décalage c'est que
comme vous avez déjà commencé à vous
bloquer de l'argent pour animer les
parties civils mais que vous en avez pas
forcément
après si vous nous laissez non non pour
les bonnes oeuvres de l'administration
pénitentiaire voilà on va vous
raccompagner c'est qu'il peut le ramener
au niveau de la porte ensuite
[Musique]
faut faire un sourire
c'est mon dernier jour à la prison je
fais partie du décor
[Musique]
et j'ai pris quelques petites habitudes
pas tout vécu qui rentre quand est-ce
qu'on boit le café
là maintenant
[Rires]
il est 7h20 du matin dans
l'administration pénitentiaire on
travaille tôt
ah j'en rêvais de celui-là dis-moi
est-ce que tu pourrais faire un appel
dans l'uvf1 pour leur dire que je vais
arriver d'ici 5 minutes ok je te
remercie cette fois je vais assister à
la fin d'un hiver celle d'une famille
complète un moment intense
je suis obligé de le faire tout
simplement le papa est incarcéré et
depuis 24 heures il est isolé dans un
des appartements avec sa femme et ses
deux petites filles d'accord et là
normalement je devrais récupérer des
petits dessins parce que les petites
filles sont adorables et en plus elles
nous font des dessins qu'on accroche sur
notre corps
Emmanuel c'est bien que la séparation va
être rune c'est donc capable de nounours
attentionné que je le vois se diriger
vers cette porte qu'il va devoir ouvrir
parce que c'est l'heure
messieurs dames bonjour ça va bien
bonjour
là je vais le mettre directement dans la
dans le dossier donc c'était bien si
vous voulez recommencer
c'est plus que bien c'est plus que bien
parce que ça fait une réadaptation aussi
surtout fait pour ça vous arrivez à
retrouver des sensations de vie
familiale
prépare à manger pour les films
[Musique]
pas de souci
il y en a pour papa aussi
ce qu'a fait le détenu quoi c'est
vachement bien parce que les enfants ils
sont grands
la petite famille s'en va le détenu lui
va regagner sa cellule c'était bien
alors
vous repartez avec quelque chose qui est
un peu d'angoisse de retourner dans la
détention
d'arrêt par exemple je sais que j'arrive
pas pu avoir ça comme un beau cadeau en
fait je pense que ma famille c'est
pareil
[Musique]
impossible de quitter l'établissement
sans prendre des nouvelles du bébé que
j'ai presque accompagné à la crèche le
premier jour
ça va
on entend de drôle de bruit
comment allez-vous
ce matin les surveillants t'ont emmené
un thermomètre électronique et sous mes
yeux j'assiste un peu ému à leur
métamorphose en infirmière
vous déplacez le terme du milieu du
front jusqu'au côté
vous savez vous en servir
bonne journée madame
bonne journée merci
de nous avoir accueilli dans votre
intimité
alors je brûle l'envie de poser à Carine
une question délicate c'est une
profession qui est pas forcément une
super réputation
Mathon vous êtes une Madone
est-ce que j'ai une tête du matin
vraiment
on montre ce qu'on veut de cette année
mais finalement vous voyez vous au
quotidien les surveillantes qui
travaillent à la nurserie et
surveillante au quotidien avec les
personnes détenues et bien ça se passe
pas comme des fois c'est décrit comment
on veut le décrire en fait mon dialogue
on discute on est à l'écoute on est sur
l'observation il faut aimer ce métier de
toute façon ça c'est sûr il faut aimer
ce métier pour pour tenir dans le temps
et puis pour pour être bien
avant de quitter la prison je veux
revoir ce condamner que j'avais
rencontré en arrivant il a connu la
vieille maison d'arrêt de Nantes avant
d'atterrir ici dans la nouvelle je veux
savoir en quoi ce genre d'établissement
high-tech a changé sa vie
il y a des gens qui ont la nostalgie de
la vieille prison
peut-être en fait ce qui se passait
beaucoup c'était après mettons après la
promenade il y avait possibilité de se
retrouver à la douche donc tout le monde
demandait la douche pour aller faire un
brin de causette à la douche donc ça
faisait une promenade supplémentaire
c'est beaucoup ça qui manque aux gens
c'est ce côté
qu'on puisse se retrouver ensemble
ce séjour était court très encadré mais
finalement passionnant cette nouvelle
génération de prison devait mettre fin
aux conditions de détention souvent
dénoncées par la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et de fait la prison
française a fait de gros progrès en
termes de respect de la dignité humaine
même si le tout informatique est l'hyper
surveillance m'inquiète un peu
[Musique]
en argot la prison c'est le ballon et
quand on est au ballon on est forcément
d'un côté ou de l'autre surveillant ou
détenus mais quand le ballon est rond
les frontières s'effacent pour la
troisième fois cette année les détenus
en bleu vont affronter les surveillants
en blanc
ils font ça toute la journée si on perd
je crois qu'on va pouvoir paraser les
murs mais il y aura des bruits de fond
de couleur quoi
je pense que le directeur va pas
supporter et puis
je pense qu'il va il va peut-être faire
les boutiques alors on va essayer de ça
se passe bien dans le meilleur sens du
terme
bien joué ça ouais aujourd'hui les
surveillants ne sont pas assez nombreux
et donc leur équipe est complétée par
deux détenus
l'un d'eux est sur le banc de touche et
il est très loyal
franchement c'est un bon match c'est
sympa
à cet instant les uniformes ont disparu
reste seulement les maillots
indépendamment de ce type de match il y
a aussi heureusement de la communication
entre les surveillants et les personnes
au quotidien c'est pas uniquement le
rapport de force constant heureusement
score fleuve mais comme un fait exprès
égalité parfaite tout un symbole dans
cet univers clos ou il n'y a pas si
longtemps encore le règlement
interdisait au surveillant et aux
détenus de se serrer la main
[Musique]
quand les uniformes réapparaissent
chacun reprend sa place de part et
d'autre des grilles
une dernière fois on me raccompagne mais
cette fois c'est vers la sortie je
retourne au grand air avec quelques
idées reçues sur la prison en moins
mon séjour ici est terminé et je repars
vers de nouveaux horizons rencontrer
d'autres hommes et d'autres femmes au
métier peu ordinaire
[Musique]